Ruth look I know I'm not a rich man  don't know the last thing about all all  I can do is promise to love you every  second of every day for the rest of my  life really  you marry me yeah cotton festive he's my  pet his name is pig don't touch him now  he is vibrating boy is he going to  explode no he's just buried why do you  have this thing is it useful does it  give meat or milk I'm gonna go you  warned the zip since when do you use the  word zip I always use the word zip I  don't like it hipster talk everybody's  zipping alpha mrs. alpha j / wrong  double alpha man candy you know time say  message your candy ass down  disrespect is real around life is binary  zeros and ones only two things keep a  group like this together fear or loyalty